Osaka interior that was built in you
know an old subway station
we try to mix this traditional samurai
kind of way of life and their Aesthetics
and their and the artwork that dates
back to the 1600s I use that as a base
as a foundation
and what can we do to make it modern day
contemporary so for example the exhibit
room I framed all these old beautiful
rice paper paintings and frame them in
glass and put modern frames around them
and put them all over the place as a
modern art gallery or our Modern Art
Space would be
[Music]
that transition from the interior of the
hotel to the exterior streets of Osaka
we figured it'd be great to have them go
through a traditional bamboo zen garden
we took over about four or five acres of
property and we created our own bamboo
that was shipped in from all over Europe
we have over 50 sticks of bamboo with
waterfalls and a rock garden and cherry
trees we kind of were able to create our
own little backyard to the hotel it was
fun thing to do
foreign
I'm enjoying my hotel Osaka Continental
very much
[Music]